c'est un geste réalisé des dizaines de
fois par jour par les usagers mais
depuis ce lundi à saint quentin en
yvelines plus besoin de toucher le
bouton stop un hologramme le remplace je
trouve que c'est très bien je m'étais
pas rendu compte
et là je découvre un nouveau système
c'est très bien moi je trouve que c'est
c'est bien quoi enfin avec tout ce qui
se passe en ce moment avec le kobe 19
c'est bien dans les transports en commun
le principe de l'auto stop c'est une
écran lcd qui est réfléchie par des
miroirs et ses miroirs enchaîne cette
image dans l'air en forme d'hologramme
on avait juste à toucher du doigt
l'image qui est dans cette ère pour
activer la demande d'arrêt qui se trouve
dans les véhicules
cinq bus de deux lignes sont pour le
moment équipés de ce système la 401
religion maurepas à versailles et la 415
permettant d'aller de bois d'arcy au
mesnil saint denis
elle transporte eu mille personnes
chaque jour la réflexion on l'avait on
l'avait depuis depuis casier un an donc
c'était c'était bien avant heureusement
effectivement avec la colline 19 ça a
précipité et on s'est dit effectivement
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il faut qu'on le
dit non on inaugure pour rassurer les
clients vous savez les transports
publics sont sûrs aujourd'hui lancé
lundi 7 décembre l'expérimentation va
durer deux mois
à terme ratp dev espère équiper les 170
véhicules du réseau stibus et la
développer dans votre société de
transport